[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
consacré aux relations des français et
du droit dans une atmosphère
probablement de contestation du droit et
de la justice
et cette émission a lieu à l'occasion de
la rentrée solennelle de la faculté de
droit de l'université de versailles
saint quentin le 18 novembre marie mam
boursiers bonjour vous êtes doyen de
cette faculté de droit donc c'est vous
allez expliquer pourquoi ils ont 13 sous
label il n'a pas dans toutes les
universités je suppose non exactement
c'est une tradition maintenant ça fait
la 15e rentrée solennelle qui a pour but
d'honorer les étudiants les plus
méritants de la faculté et que lui aussi
de montrer notre communauté
universitaire avec fierté dans les
missions de service public nous
accomplissons alors je des doyens de là
j'ai pas osé mettre d'articles on dit le
doyen la doyenne la doyenne non parce
que probablement il ya des incidents qui
sont plus âgés que vous dans votre degré
doyenne non parce que c'est comme les
points du milieu je préfère éviter et en
revanche doyen où le doyen me
frédéric champagne bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le bâtonnier du barreau de
versailles depuis deux ans vous arrivez
de presse qu fin de monde à la fin de
mandat fin décembre je laisserai la
place à mon successeur c'est un
soulagement une au contraire un regret
au nom il ya du regret il ya plus de
regrets de soulagement j'aurais bien
continuer encore un petit peu oui le
bâtonnat dure 2 ans 1/2 en classe avec l
impossibilité de se présenter à l'issue
avant d'être cars mais sinon vous aurez
été bâtonnier avis non m
je ferai payer un bonjour bonjour alors
c'est peut-être un jour bâtonnier vous
êtes en tout cas avocat au barreau de
versailles et vous êtes secrétaire de la
conférence du stage
donc absolument et moi aussi je rends le
mandat à la fin de cette année et oui
c'est ça ça c'est beau deux ans aussi ce
alors en principe c'est que pour un an
mais les circonstances à brigitte eu
l'air dans lesquelles s'est déroulé
notre mandat en 2020 a conduit alors un
bâtonnier généreux voilà à renouveler
notre mandat pour une année
supplémentaire donc nous nous avons été
je crois que nous sommes peut-être la
seule promotion avoir été secrétaire de
la conférence pendant deux ans en raison
des circonstances particulières liées à
l'épidémie covin halal à l'épisode du
coc vite voilà bahima boursiers donc
cette rentrée solennelle de la deûle à
fait le droit vous l'avez place et
justement sur le le spectre des
relations entre les universitaires et
des avocats voilà il s'agit de mettre en
avant les liens que les universités les
facultés droit en particulier ont avec
le monde judiciaire juridique donc
chaque année nous choisissons une
personnalité il ya une françois molins
c'est venu nous rendre visite le
ministre urvoas et plus naturels encore
sans doute les liens avec le barreau les
barreaux de versailles et le barreau de
paris il patonnier de tours et kuzi sera
également présent parce que une grande
majorité nos étudiants se destinant à la
profession d'avocat et que les liens
sont historiquement importante dans la
formation au fond dans les échanges dans
l'est les rangs dont sont issus les
avocats et dans nos préoccupations
communes aussi et je crois que c'est ce
sur quoi je souhaiterais mettre l'accent
ce soir autour de la liberté
d'expression qui pour nous avocats comme
universitaire et au fond l'exercice
d'une liberté professionnelle qu'il me
semble nécessaire de défendre très
ardemment
vous même vous avez été avocate oui tout
mais très brièvement j'attends reste
enseignants chercheurs je suis avocat
pénaliste spécialisés les autorisations
confiance et j'ai été avocat de son
barreau de paris pour voir un peu ce que
faisaient mes étudiants sortir du master
que je dirigeais comme messier qui n'est
pas le mien mais qui ça a été une
expérience très enrichissante rames
étaient difficiles mais un très très
beau métier il ya des liens entre eux il
ya des
des avocats qui ans à nîmes
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il ya une grosse
différence entre justement ce qu'on
apprend aujourd'hui on sait dire qu'il
est un peu la théorie du droit et puis
la pratique quand on arrive peut-être
geoffrey quand on arrive dans un cabinet
est-ce que c'est très différent oui il
ya beaucoup de choses alors
effectivement lorsqu'on arrive dans un
cabinet on découvre beaucoup de choses
qui ne sont pas nécessairement enseigné
dans le cadre de l'université mais ce
qui est absolument certain c'est que ce
que l'on apprend dans le cadre des cours
de droit qui sont dispensés sert de base
et sert de référentiel à ce que derrière
sera la pratique donc effectivement tous
les aspects pratiques d'un cabinet
d'avocats ne sont pas et ne peuvent pas
être enseignée dans le cadre de
l'université mais par contre tout le
bagage théorique nécessaire à l'exercice
de la profession et bien sûr enseigné à
l'université et c'est ça qui nous permet
derrière d'être lés professionnelles
relativement accompli notre agent pat
justement les liens entre l'université
et le barreau c'est important à celle
essentielle oui c'est l'essentiel la n
va il ya même une place de du bar au
sein du conseil d'administration de la
faculté donc j'ai une vraie interaction
et c'est vrai un échange constant sur la
formation sur la formation continue sur
la formation initiale étant précisé
effectivement que la théorie les
fondations de ce que vont devenir le les
avocats c'est la faculté les
enseignements et puis le lien la
transition entre cet enseignement
théorique ou un peu partie déjà un dans
le cas des lions dirigés va être fait
par l'école d'avocats ensuite durant le
temps de la formation avec les stages
avec une formation un peu plus axé sur
la pratique que l'université mais les
deux n'existerait pas l'un sans l'autre
enfin il me semble que c'est fondamental
parce que vous évoquez c'est à dire que
l'objet de l'université c'est la théorie
c'est pas un gros mot c'est la théorie
c'est vraiment lent parce que certains
étudiants ont finalement nous réclame
plus de pratique on les apprend on leur
apprend à réfléchir on leur apprend à
l'université cela pour ça raisonner à
chercher
et c'est notre rôle et les avocats
remplissent très bien leurs rôles aussi
dans les écoles professionnelles qui
sont des écoles d'application dont il ya
vraiment de rôle d'une grande
complémentarité entre nos professions
oui d'ailleurs il ya maintenant ce qui
n'existait pas autrefois mais une école
d'avocat sein d'une formation avec une
formation qui est à la fois qu'on dirait
qualifié de théorique même si elle est
là c'est elle est accentuée sur l'aspect
pratique de la profession et puis des
stages au sein des cabinets pour la
cette fois envisagé la mise en
application de la théorie apprise à
l'université alors les sources
traditionnelles et droit il ya
évidemment la loi a applaudi la
jurisprudence si le nom et la doctrine
là la doctrine c'est plutôt vous et la
james follows c'est plutôt
pourrait dire ça comme ça oui il faut
rester très modestes je pense que la
doctrine accompagne donne des idées
anticipe aussi les rebelles membres
internet
la procréation médicalement assistée il
ya beaucoup de sujets de société dont on
parlera certainement tout à l'heure qui
initie de nouveaux mouvements de
nouvelles demandes nouveau préjudice au
fond donc la doctrine est chargé au fond
d'accompagner d'expliquer cela et puis
de former ensuite les étudiants c'est la
spécificité de l'université la formation
à l'université est basé sur la recherche
en fallait de cette recherche est ce
qu'écrivent les enseignants-chercheurs
et comment ils analysent et la
jurisprudence les évolutions
jurisprudentielles législatives est ce
que vous direz qu on est dans un monde
justement où le le droit évolue de plus
en plus vite
alors elle demande peut être c'est à
dire qu'on a quand même aujourd'hui une
réac ce fait il ya souvent on pourrait
presque associés dans certaines matières
en tout cas une réforme d'un fait-divers
sévère qu'on attend une réponse non
législative un fait divers dont on
estime un peu rapidement d'ailleurs que
la solution ne se trouve pas dans le
droit dans le droit positif ce qui est
pas toujours le cas soyons très clairs
donc oui il ya une il ya une réponse qui
est quelquefois peut-être un petit peu
un peu trop impulsive on va dire un peu
trop épidermique comprend pas le temps
de la réflexion à légifère pour
s'apercevoir ensuite que les dispositifs
existaient peut-être déjà qu'il fallait
d'abord les mettre en application avant
de les critiquer
très vrai en procédure pénale devenu
quasi incompréhensible et inabordable
presque pour les magistrats j'imagine
aussi que pour les avocats alors moi je
trouve ça très complexe l'enchevêtrement
des l'enchevêtrement des modifications
qui répondent souvent en effet plus à
une pression médiatique à une besoin
juridique mais après il ya un phénomène
de fond qui est quand même la
complexification des rapports sociaux de
la complexification du aussi à la
mondialisation qui appelle aussi de
nouveaux échanges et donc de nouvelles
réponses d'une liaison puis les deux
phénomènes sont certainement mêlée alors
abordé le premier thème de cette édition
est justement balade poussé il ya des
phénomènes contradictoires yahia la
poussée du droit il ya peut-être la
contestation du droit aussi mais il ya
vrai vous me parlez de peut-être d'une
inflation d'aider des normes fin des
règles juridiques c'est ça fait partie
de cette poussée du droit c'est le
premier thème de cette émission
[Musique]
alors il ya un mot qu'on difficile à
prononcer et je vais essayer
judiciarisation de la société
ça existe vraiment
c'est que on va de plus en plus hors ou
au procès
pas totalement certain d'autant que la
tendance actuelle y compris législatives
et de favoriser de plus en plus la
médiatisation c'est à dire que la
médiation par dont la médiatisation
médiatisation ses salades et travaille
dans la médiation qui peut même devenir
un après un préambule obligatoire dans
certaines procédures c'est à dire que il
est demandé de manière impérative au
parti de chercher d'abord si aucune
médiation n'est possible avant de
judiciariser le le différend qui les
oppriment mais non non je pour le coup
je suis parfaitement d'accord avec
monsieur le bâtonnier sur ce sujet là
alors je suis d'accord avec lui non pas
parce qu'ils les bâtonniers parce que je
pense exactement la même chose alors je
vais vous avez tenté judiciarisation je
vais me tenter à déjudiciarisation c'est
vrai que c'est le c'est l'avant c'est la
grande tendance actuelle où on voit que
dans beaucoup de matière on sort de
l'office du juge certaines prérogatives
pour permettre que soient les partis
soient des intervenants externes qui ne
sont pas des intervenants nécessairement
judiciaire puisse proposer des solutions
alors soit un litige soit lorsqu'il ya
un accord que cet accord puisse être mis
en place je pense notamment au divorce
par consentement mutuel qui a été d
judiciariser ya deux ans où elle veille
à plein du giro ne fait plus intervenir
le juge en réalité ce sont les avocats
qui rédige keith alors un avocat pour
chaque parti qui se mettent d'accord sur
les modalités de divorce qui ensuite
rédiger une convention elles à fond
derrière enregistré par un notaire on ne
passe plus à la sof la réponse à la
visite et l'embouteillage des tribunaux
non mais c'est vrai qu'on a dû sortir un
certain nombre de deux domaines du
refuge parce que j'avais trop d'affaires
non c'est plutôt ça qui est bien loin
oui je pense que le développement actuel
des modes alternatifs d'aidé de
règlement des différends il est très
clairement aussi une réponse du monde de
la justice à la suffisance 2001 et vite
on l'engorgement des des juridictions
qui de toute façon n'ont pas les moyens
de faire face à la ala demande des
justiciables mais vous parliez tout à
l'heure de liberté d'expression
on a l'impression quand même
qu'aujourd'hui enfin autrefois ça
pouvait se se résoudre dans un débat
dans une confrontation
aujourd'hui on va volontiers au procès
non on en voit beaucoup de procès sur
les presque dire malheureusement non
enfin sur un point les plus pressés sans
doute alors peut-être pour revenir si
vous le permet sur cette question
judiciaire les rongeait un point de vue
un peu peut-être décalé par rapport à
cela si on s'inscrit dans le temps je
pense qu'il ya eu un phénomène de
judiciarisation et ça dépend de ce qu'on
entend par cette citation ci c'est la
place croissante
l'institution judiciaire fut ce au sens
large dans la vie de la société je moi
je parlerai quand même de
judiciarisation sans avoir les votre
expérience au contentieux donc plus
largement avec l'implication des acteurs
sociaux qui saisissent le jugeront avec
aussi la justice qui est sollicité pour
résoudre des questions de société qui
après renvoie à d'autres instances plus
à même de le faire et puis quand même
sans doute avec la place des affaires
politiques qui arrive dans la sphère
judiciaire et tout cela pour moi fait
partie de cette judiciarisation parce
que je pense que ça a vraiment une
implication sur la conception de l'état
au fond et pour répondre plus
précisément votre question sur la
liberté d'expression jeu aujourd'hui il
me semble que le danger ne vient pas de
l'état ne vient pas des pouvoirs de
pouvoir de façon extérieur comme ça je
pense que le danger vient plutôt d'un
mélange de médiatisation d' influence de
politiquement correct de culture de
l'annulation qui font un cocktail
détonnant d'autocensure au fond de
certains d'entre nous dont les avocats
potentiellement les enseignants
chercheurs et pour moi le vrai risque
aujourd'hui d'atteinte à la liberté
d'expression c'est celui à c'est à dire
une forme d'autocensure
des uns des autres pour ne pas mettre ou
s'exposer à des critiques de groupes de
pression qui ont promeuvent des
sensibilités alors ma difficulté avec
cela c'est que moi j'ai ma sensibilité
vous avez la vôtre
laquelle est plus légitime que l'autre
moi je ne laisse le législateur décider
de cela pas un groupe de pression voyez
donc c'est quand cela pour moi que au
fond quand on arrive devant un tribunal
en droit de la presse en droit pénal de
la presse on est sur quelque chose qui
est au fond le mérite d'être tranchée
par le droit et c'est tout ce qui se
passe hors droits qui pour moi est plus
préoccupant aujourd'hui en droit c'est
agir sur les réseaux sociaux voilà
mais dans notre vie quotidienne la
faculté a organisé il y a deux ans la
projection d'un film dans le cadre de
nos partenariats avec le cinéma de 50
ans du film de roman polanski
oui ça va nous avons dû réaliser cette
projection sous protection policière
parce que j'ai eu des lettres de menaces
d'associations d'étudiants tu es
considéré que les soupçons et ou avérées
ou non en tout cas encore judiciairement
trancher sur le territoire français de
l'infraction reprochée à roman polanski
devait supprimer enfin entraîné la
suppression cette programmation donc on
fait un procès robben sont inscrits mais
pourquoi pas
à balzac et c'est donc sur quels fonds
non loi sur des sur des
voiliers enfin le monde exposent plus
aujourd'hui parce que c'est ça c'est ça
la culture de l'avenue nation et ça
nécessite un choix social de notre
contrat social et c'est préoccupant dont
vous seul e cette tendance justement à
la censure 20
en fait on va confier le rôle de juge à
des gens qui n'en sont pas c'est à dire
que chacun va se retrouver devant avec
un niveau d'information dont on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il est d'abord prend sa
source dans les réseaux sociaux ce qui
est une vraie préoccupation et puis qui
va donner le sentiment à celui qui lit
tout ça qu'il est apte à juger en
méconnaissant la règle de droit peu
importe car ce faisant une opinion sur
l'opinion des autres et ça c'est
dramatique c'est à dire que le procès on
se demande aujourd'hui où il a lieu et
quel est le plus sévère qu'elle est plus
sévère c'est hors les murs
voilà et c'est vrai que la la
l'augmentation est l'inflation
d'utilisation des réseaux sociaux n'a
pas arrangé les choses et à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a quand même beaucoup
de choses qui passent et ça a des vertus
sa serviette vertu notamment celle de
l'information mais ça sans doute des
défauts c'est assez celui de la
nécessaire autocensure de ceux qui ne
veulent pas se retrouver jugé part de
ceux qui ne sont pas jugés qui n'ont
commis aucune infraction mais ne sont
pas d'accord ont une opinion différente
ce que vous expliquez tout à l'heure et
ne veulent pas prendre le risque d'être
critiqués ou
très clairement vilipendé ces mêmes
réseaux il ya une des questions qui se
posent d'ailleurs c'est celle de la
prescription dont beaucoup d'affaires
parce que c'est vrai que
parfois l'opinion après je suis passé
l'âge de raison ou tort mais s'empare
d'affaires que la justice ne peut plus
connaître puisque puisque les faits sont
prescrits
les affaires de viols dans les affaires
d'affaires polanski par exemple un peu
dans ce genre la fin on voit qu'elle a
été jugé mais
ça pose des problèmes quand même il ya
un décalage
mais quand
on voit qu'il ya un vrai glissement en
réalité on comprend que ces affaires là
qui devrait rester dans un giron qui
serait strictement judiciaire rentre
finalement dans une problématique
médiatique et que sans avoir
l'intégralité des éléments qui composent
un dossier qui cause une infraction qui
pourrait être reproché les gens émettent
des avis émettent des opinions sur
quelque chose qui aurait dû en principe
rester dans le giron de la justice et ça
c'est très vrai et ça on est sain en
démocratie c'est une vraie vraie
problématique et il va faire très très
actuel qui concerne la présomption
d'innocence on parle beaucoup de la
présomption d'innocence c'est un
principe ne sont pas n'importent pas un
humoriste qui est accusé de viol et pour
l'instant il est mis en examen mais mis
en examen on bénéficie de la présomption
d'innocence et il devait être le héros
d'une série la chaîne qui qui qui devait
l'employé a rompu son contrat bon on
peut comprendre les bases de sa venue
enfin il ya
la présomption d'innocence il aurait dû
être enfin sous contrat aurait dû
continuer on peut comprendre aussi
l'action h&m qui se dit oui mais si s'il
s'avère que les gueux les faits sont
réels ça pose un problème donc c'est
compliqué c'est l'application de ces
principes mais est ce que c'est un
principe tel qu'on l'entend le droit de
ne pas être présenté comme coupable ça
ne résiste pas à la version lite est le
vrai principe pour moi de présomption
d'innocence ont donc pénalise c'est au
fond la question de la charge de la
preuve techniquement c'est ça la
présomption d'innocence respecter c'est
que vous êtes un citoyen étant vous
n'avez pas été déclarés coupables et que
la juridiction n'a pas dé montrez votre
fiabilité vous êtes innocent la elle
joue à plein ce principe joue à plein
sur l'aspect de présentation de votre
personne comme quelqu'un qui n'est pas
coupable donc il n'a pas été jugé par
une juridiction judiciaire
bon là ça n'existe pas
les gens qui sont qui sont poursuivies
qui utilisent ce nom c'est aussi dans
notre imaginaire collectif qui
considérons que la présomption
d'innocence et à toutes ses conséquences
mais elle ne les a pas parce que vous
êtes jugés par le tribunal médiatique et
voilà la chaîne réagi à cela et on
comprend on peut pas
dire qu'il ya deux aspects et il ya le
premier aspect qui est celui qui est
purement juridique et qu'effectivement
il faut respecter de manière impérative
la présomption d'innocence et il ya
l'autre aspect qui est un aspect
peut-être plus commercial dans lequel la
chaîne dit bon là j'ai effectivement on
a des soupçons sur cet humoriste enfin
il des soupçons pèsent sur des humains
sur cet humoriste est ce qu'on peut
présenter la série dans laquelle il
était censé jouer est ce que dans cet
imaginaire collectif ça va avoir la
rentabilité que ça aurait dû avoir si
jamais il n'avait pas été préalablement
mis en examen dans cette affaire là et
il ya une autre difficulté avec la
présomption d'innocence que l'on voit
beaucoup
dans des affaires qui sont médiatiques
c'est finalement son pendant c'est la
violation du secret de l'instruction
quand c'est le secret de l'instruction
et sa violation
je pense notamment
à cette affaire à cette affaire du
billard dans le dans le tarn où on suit
quasiment
suis quasiment en direct les
et les éléments qui sont qui sont
contenues en procédure
je lisais le c'était le parisien dans le
parisien la semaine dernière où ils ont
retranscrit quasiment l'intégralité de
l'audition que si eric gillard a eu
devant le juge d'instruction ça ça pose
un vrai problème si à la fin de cette
affaire cédric jubilaire bénéficie d'un
non-lieu ou qu'il est déclaré non
coupable par une cour d'assises bon
qu'est ce qui restera de cela qu est ce
qui restera de l'innocence qui aura été
judiciairement déclaré dans le dans les
médias dont l'opinion publique qu'il
aura été du fait de la violation de
secret de l'instruction nécessairement
vilipendé à un moment comme un potentiel
coupable et c'est ça qui restera et on
aura deux réalités la première réalité
sera là la réalité judiciaire de liège
et l'autre réalité sera mis en vente de
culpabilité malgré tout
pardon non j'allais ajouter qu'il ya un
vrai problème de sémantique également
dans la communication des affaires
judiciaires on entend très souvent est
alors le combat pour le respect de la
présomption d'innocence devient un voeu
pieux c'est qu'on entend le l'expression
présumé coupable quand même on l'entend
très souvent lors de la présentation
d'un procès d'une instance dans le
présumé coupable en entend parler de
victimes et n'ont pas de partie civile
le jugement est quand même déjà un peu
fait à l'avancé il est très compliqué je
me suis en cette mesurette qui était qui
consistait à ne plus diffuser l'image de
quelqu'un de menotter alors on le note
on le présente avec les mains dans le
dos floutés mais il en quadrette de
policiers avec une capuche sur la tête
il sort d'un fourgon pénitentiaire dans
un palais de justice ont cessé ou bien
on interdit ce genre d'image parce
qu'elles considèrent qu'elle porte
atteinte à la présomption d'innocence et
ce n'est pas faux de voir quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui comparaît détenu il est un
peu moins présumé innocent que quelqu'un
qui les sépare est libre ce sont des
choses qui sont évidentes donc je fais
vraiment aprem de culture générale de la
présentation de du procès pour les fois
il faut et on l'entend souvent quand le
la notion de présumé coupable vend plus
que la notion de vie ou alors on
accumule les charges et puis on dit à la
fin mais il est présumé innocent
mais le mal est fait et je le disais je
ferais muller est parfaitement exact
c'est à dire quid de l'impact d'une
décision de relaxe au bénéfice du doute
alors que une campagne en ce cas là de
médiatisation a présenté la personne n'y
a pas de fumée sans feu
mais je pense aussi que certains doutes
de certains de certains mise en examen
par leurs actions notamment je pense au
monde politique cette espèce de réflexe
de réclamer ou de d'anticiper de
démissionner de ses fonctions parce
qu'on est mise en examen c'est déjà
envoyé un très mauvais message c'est à
dire je laissais la jurisprudence
balladur c'est oublier sa sinistre
toujours ensuite dire que le mise en
examen est présumé innocent mais ce sont
des présumés innocents qui démissionne
donc je me retire le temps de ces déjà
forcément un message qui est une
culpabilité présumée plus que
d'innocence présumés pots pour la ce qui
est ce qui est de la du secret de
l'instruction
et bien quelqu'un qui donne des
informations ça bien sûr veut travailler
c'est vrai enfin vous allez dire que
c'est bien plutôt déçu
non non non les avocats parfois nous
intéressent à moi ça m'est arrivé des
avocats lui le jeu des règles est
bafouée par celui qui a intérêt en
général vous savez c'est simple si le
dossier beauvais ça vient pas de la
défense elle fait d'eux les sources
outre soir sont les en brut et à la 3c
le ministère public c'est les services
enquêteurs etc les avocats et sur ceux
qui ont accès au dossier on peut
imaginer une périphérie mais
généralement c'est une espèce de
communication parce qu'elle sert les
intérêts soit l'accusation sueur de
l'effort la défense soyons très clairs
moi j'ai vu des dossiers dans lesquels
les procès verbaux de police étaient
dans la presse avant d'arriver sur le
bureau du juge aurait aimé césaire mais
cette arrivée à ses fins drôle d'effet
si vous êtes d'ailleurs l'intéressé en
ou rapports entre le droit pénal et la
médiatisation je crois
est ce que ça change au fond et oui la
présence des médias et notamment mais
aujourd'hui en plus il ya les des
chaînes d'info continue donc il faut
faire événement à tout moment est ce que
ça change au fond de la façon de
considérer de le droit pénal peut-être
le métier des juges ou métier d avocat
réponse je pense que plus largement il
ya dans cette médiatisation j'y inclurai
le travail et les revendications des
associations
la question du lanceur d' alerte par
exemple paraît quand même en lien avec
cette question-là de la médiatisation
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
des institutions aussi complètement
privées qui vont avoir un rôle de
procureurs privés presque d'initiation
et au fond de mise en pâture de
situation de personnalités pour des
revendications politiques juridiques etc
qui peuvent être très légitime donc ça
ça j'espère que la procédure ait des
règles de la théorie générale de droit
pénal ne résiste pas à cela les
magistrats l'appliquer heureusement
sommes dans un état de droit dans une
démocratie mais ça dépasse complètement
la sphère juridique là on est sur des
rapports de force qui sont très
différents et puis peut-être sur la
question de la place de la victime qui
ne cessent de sa vie droite ça ça fait
partie aussi vraiment une vieille
obsession
judiciarisation de la société par une
renaissance alors je pense basé sur les
travaux sur des travaux sociologiques
logique et ses acquis qui disent que
c'est nécessaire mais ça a changé aussi
leur apportent eux pensent des victimes
à la justice pénale est en tout cas de
la façon dont elles sont perçues dans
les médias avec un statut qui est
reconnue beaucoup plus fortement donc
tout ce cocktail party finalement je
trouve fait reculer l'importance de la
règle de droit là qui est dépassé par
par ces pressions extérieures médiatique
et social là on est en plein appel du
procès fillon par exemple ça a été est
ce que est ce que sur un plan de théorie
pénale ses études à fait intéressante ça
oui
non parce que ça c'est beaucoup discuté
il ya un empressement du parquet il ya 2
2 il ya deux aspects à mon avis qu'on
doit considérer dans cette affaire
fillon la première c'est que alors
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
procèdent d'une enquête qui avait été
préalablement fait et l'ouverture de
cette information judiciaire a été
réalisée par ce que il y avait au moment
où ça a été fait une difficulté de
prescription sur certaines périodes dans
lesquelles il y avait des suspicions sur
françois fillon ça c'est le premier
aspect le deuxième aspect c'est celui à
lors de la mise en examen de la mise en
examen qui a été réalisée peut être trop
hâtivement qui auraient été réalisés
trop hâtivement de françois fillon mais
est-ce qu'on doit pas alors le juge
n'était pas tenu finalement par la
promesse de françois fillon c'est lui
seul qui vient sur le plateau de tf1 et
qui dit je me retirais si je suis mais
il est loin l'alléger pas comptable de
la promesse politique électorale de
francs seule chose qui devrait vous
intéresser si j'étais bien exactement et
on devrait s qu'on n'aurait pas dû
considérer est ce qu'on pourrait pas
considérer l inverse que s'il n'avait
pas été mis en examen au motif qu'il
avait fait cette promesse là serait pas
été encore plus scandaleux donc à mon
sens la question l'empressement elle se
pose pas assez françois fillon tout seul
qui sait
on écrivait dans son propre piège et
finalement l enquête elle a suivi des
délais relativement normaux derrière
l'élection présidentielle c'est terminé
il à l'information judiciaire aussi il a
comparu devant un tribunal correctionnel
maintenant il ya un appel jeu en tout
cas sur le plan strict de de la
procédure pénale et de l'empressement
possible du parquet ou d'une
interférence du judiciaire dans le
politique
ça personnellement alors peut-être que
autour de cette table on aura un avis
différent de moi j'y vois rien de
spécialement choquant
celui qu'on évoquait tout à leur staff
les magistrats sont soumis à une
pression ici il ya une pression
médiatique sur comment voulez vous ne
pas répondre à cette pression d'un je
crois que c'est très difficile de bien
passer pas une pression de la hiérarchie
au sens strict du terme c'est que chaque
magistrat des dents quand on est aussi
visible que ce dont nous pouvons parler
aussi forcément des objectifs
stratégiques de guerre qu'elles sont
tout à fait légitime mais qui font que
il ya une réponse qui est aussi une
réponse de communication mais qui le
sens de l'être la voilà ce combiné avec
des réalités juridiques
j'y vois rien non plus oui je pense
qu'il faut pas non plus tomber dans une
espèce de deux de paranoïa l'idée est
une
internationalisation du lez je n'ai pas
le sentiment qu'il ya un traitement ni
de défaveur ni de faveur encore une fois
le premier lien qui est fait entre eux
la candidature est là l'addition
judiciaire c'est le candidat lui-même
qui la télévision et après tout peut se
dire que c'est peut-être pas plus mal
qu'on apprenne avoir une élection ce qui
se passe plutôt qu'après
politiquement valls très de fatick sa
difficulté cette difficulté c'est qu'il
avait fait campagne sur une forme louise
sur la sonate et une fin et demeurant
ils veulent contradictions me parle et
là effectivement de nouveau essayé s'est
retrouvé prisonnier du propre piège
qu'il avait lui même tissé mais ce peut
être un terreau ceux du parquet national
financé sa sas a
dû monter une sorte de contestation du
juge et c'est là le deuxième thème de
notre l'émission la contestation de vue
[Musique]
là on est en pleine campagne
présidentielle
et on entend partout des candidats qui
disent comment mêler les juges les juges
annihile l'action des policiers y kodad
les délinquants sont laissés en liberté
c'est vrai qu'une accusation très forte
1 contre l'as de de laxisme de la
justice quoi vous en pensez quoi c'est
tellement facile oui recueille et c'est
tellement facile des appelants montagnon
pascal mais parce que c'est difficile de
making droit paix mais bien sûr c'est à
dire que le message simple prend c'est
pour ça qu'à beaucoup de danger au fond
c'est un problème de fond un problème
d'éducation de culture au fond à la
réflexion
mais je le problème beaucoup plus
globale il est très ancien on ressort à
chaque élection ce sont les mêmes
accusations au fond il ya cette méfiance
du politique à l'égard de la justice
pour des raisons qu'on comprend bien
qu'ils sont justifiées mais pas papa par
le soupçon d'instrumentalisation de la
justice mme sans doute par un travail
encore à faire sur la probité publique
je crois que c'est quand même cela et
puis le deuxième aspect c'est que je me
souviens plus du prix de votre question
ça c'est
la favède de cette accusation de laxisme
de la complexité aussi d'expliquer que
le droit c'est aussi non respect des
formes c'est aussi le respect d'une
procédure
c'est vrai que non mais on peut
comprendre l'opinion qui se dire voilà
un type
délinquants qui est arrêté par les par
les politiques des relations média tu
m'en parlait justice on peut comprendre
que ça interroge oui et non je pense
quand même que c'est souvent fantasmée
que d'un d'un fait divers ridicule y est
c'est à dire d'une attraction réitéré ou
d'une récidive on va faire une règle
générale c'est à dire que moi je le
laxisme judiciaire que je fréquente pas
au quotidien ou alors je joue alors je
suis très mauvais très mauvais dossier
mais je fréquente pas des magistrats
laxistes je aller en comparution
immédiate que ceux qui prétendent que la
justice est laxiste assise à une
audience ou deux pour voir que les gars
des incarcérations qu'il ya des mandats
de dépôt immédiat qui n'est pas vrai que
quand tu as policiers interpellent le
lendemain la personne est dehors préfère
commencer ça n'est pas vrai et ça arrive
mais le risque zéro n'existe pas en
matière de justice si vous ne prenez pas
le risque social alors cette c'est
inaudible je l'entends pour la victime
de celui qui a réitéré mais pour un qui
réitère d'autres ne réitère pas et on ne
vous ne pouvez pas prendre de risque
social d'une espèce d' aveuglement
répressif sous prétexte que certains
qu'ils bénéficient encore une fois non
pas du laxisme et de normes applicables
ainsi de la même juge qui inventent
l'annoncé va donc non en tout cas le
laxisme judiciaire général moi j'ai
l'impression que ça n'est pas la réalité
que je côtoie en tant qu'abonné vous
entendez l'accusation oui bien sûr j'ai
répondu quoi oui mais je suis regardé
dans cette période peuvent toujours dû
dès qu'on est en période électorale là
en plus faut être très clair il ya un
sentiment d'insécurité qui a de nombreux
visages donc cela délinquance en étant
bien à d'autres et il est facile vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est tellement
facile de le dire oui il est peut-être
ils seront peut-être aussi intéressant
de le démontrer parce que ça permettrait
de mieux réfléchir aux solutions qui
sont les bonnes il a ce fantasme de
laxisme généralisé sur la petite
délinquance mais paraît encore une fois
non conformes à la réalité que je
connais mal et même si vous parliez tout
à l'heure de complexification de la
procédure pénale qui permet sans doute
on dit souvent que les très bons avocats
pénalistes ans souvent
ddsp site de procédures peine
mes bobos forcément écornée mais miliana
enfin je ne partage pas tout à fait tout
à fait cette cette opinion sur la
complexité ou la trop grande complexité
de la procédure pénale c'est qu'il ya
certains aspects de droit pénal et de
procédure pénale qui à un moment vienne
s'enchevêtrer qui rendent parfois le
contenu un peu indigeste ça je peux
l'entendre par contre sur le fait qu'un
certain nombre de normes viennent
encadrer
la perspective d'une privation de
liberté d'une personne mise en cause moi
ça me semble être tout à fait
satisfaisant un moment lorsque l'on voit
les enjeux qui sont tant qu'ils sont mis
en balance le fait que derrière une
procédure pénale fut-elle un peu
complexe vienne garantir cela ça me
sembla être un équilibrage dans le
rapport de force qui me semble à mon
sens plutôt satisfaisant même si
j'entends que le corps n'est pas
excessivement parfait mais je peux en
fait ça dépend de ce qu'on appelle
complexifie kenzo et moi c'est le je
pense que vraiment l'empilement
unités par exemple le mot khoury
magistrats eux-mêmes comme les policiers
ont des difficultés à identifier la
règle a bien appliqué bien sûr un corps
de garanties dans un état démocratique
c'est fondamental je vous rejoins
complètement je parle de mes de ses
réponses aux faits divers on va ajouter
une loi et tout ça se superposent
s'enchevêtrent il ya plus de direction
générale au fond et je crois que pour
les magistrats comme pour les
justiciables c'est une difficulté la
compréhension par le justiciable qu'ils
soient victimes ou auteurs du sens des
règles qu'on va lui appliquer me paraît
fondamental et c'est cette complexité là
qui me semble exister aujourd'hui qui
nécessiterait un vrai toilettage qui
supposera un travail de fou et c'est
toute la difficulté parce que ce n'est
pas rentable mais qu'elles sont un pour
les politiques un travail de fond et qui
serait en plus dépourvus de toute
pression politique alors justement
contre en revanche
simplement à la question stricte de la
règle de droit et de pâtes et non de
toutes les interférences politiques qui
peut y avoir lorsque lorsqu'on fait du
droit pénal et de la procédure pénale
c'est ce que vous dénonciez tout l'a320
c'est à dire mais qui est un fait divers
fait ce que je me disais on pourrait
presque associer le nom d'un fait divers
à chaque réforme d'importance de la
procédure pénale ou ou du droit pénal
d'ailleurs presque j'avais d'ailleurs
dans un état dans un dossier récent et
dramatique on a même proposé que la
réforme législative porte le nom de la
victime d'envoyer que c'est pas une
fiction c'est bien une règle jeanne un
fait divers dramatique monstrueux mais
c'est la réponse à un fait divers qui
fait réfléchir tous les professionnels
et rapidement parce qu'il faut une
réponse politique très rapide et
rapidement et avec un phénomène
d'empilement qui nous coupe faim nous
rend la tâche très complexe et que je
sois au niveau des magistrats des
maudits policiers en fin de du service
enquêteur les gendarmes et policiers et
puis du service des avocats parce
qu'encore une fois on ne se souciait pas
forcément des modifications
périphériques d'une réforme qui est
destiné à rennes apporte une réponse
très ciblée les deux notions baudinet
larry ma bourse il a devancé les
spécialistes y aura des efforts de
simplification vendait des tentatives de
simplification du code pénal du code de
procédure pénale et est-ce que rien ce
qui est un besoin d'ailleurs de ça
le code pénal je vous rejoins moins sûr
je trouve comme a failli et des réformes
mais
il était peut-être en droit des peines
voilà c'est plus instable mais je trouve
quand même qu'à une plus grande
stabilité du code pénal qui me paraît
assez clair je trouve bien rédigé enfin
globalement je le situerais mois la
problématique sur le code pénal sur la
description des interactions avec des
peines que sur la procédure pénale il ya
eu des procès des tentatives de
dépénalisation de toilettage de message
plus clair à envoyer mais qui n'ont été
toujours que partiel alors je ne sais
pas ce que les états généraux de la
justice
si nous contribuons les uns les autres a
essayé d'appeler à ce type de réformes
et ça n'a pas été un mouvement massif ça
cette simplification je crois que
vraiment je ne crois pas avoir perçu que
c'est une priorité du législateur en
procédure pénale mais ce que parmi les
blessés rechercher d or s'il ya des des
travaux là dessus sur wii alors bien sûr
il ya des spécialistes de procédure
pénale dont je ne suis pas je veux ça y
est bien sûr bien sûr il ya des appels
mais en même temps les enseignants
chercheurs comme dans toute la société
ceci père spécialise parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est en paix les lis
moi je ne peux pas suivre aussi finement
il droit pénal général elle droit pénal
spécial et la procédure pénal droit
pénal européen et de valises pénale
internationale donc il ya aussi ce
phénomène qui ne permet pas d'appeler
tant que ça une réforme plus globale
donc je crois que c'est ça reste quand
même
un sujet qui ne paraît difficile à
résoudre ce que je peux poser une
question à la zemmour
il ya une féminisation des professions
judiciaires de je crois qu'à vers
versailles le le barreau le plus féminin
le français n'a vraiment rien pour
chantage en sorte un joueur pour
chantage bien évidemment que des
barreaux qui ont un effectif beaucoup
plus nombreux en plus de femmes avocates
mes visions de chantage au plus on est
après sa 62 66 68 68 pour soi mais
depuis pratiquement les années 50 voilà
on est le donc oui c'est vrai c'est pas
forcément récents non non non non on
peut même s'étonner que ce soit
versailles avec la réputation
quelquefois que me qu'on lui attribue
qu'ils soient le fer de lance de cette
modernité depuis les années 50 nous
sommes le barreau le plus féminisé de
france ayez une féminisation de la
magistrature je dis pas que
c'est pour féminisation donc là ce
laxisme mais est ce qu est ce que ça non
trois ans plus tôt le 6
mai mais est ce que ça change un peu la
l'appréhension enfin de love la face aux
gros de la justice au
pouvoir pense qu'il ya un principe
auquel nous nous nous astreignons c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de sexe sous la robe je
pense que c'est tout à fait la même
chose pour les magistrats et l'ensemble
des professions du droit uss ponce coup
dur pour le lien nécessaire entre
la féminisation et quelques
événements enfants quelques événements
ou circonstances que l'on pourrait
constater en tout cas moi je vis plus la
culture des justiciables culture
individuelle de chaque justiciable qui
peut être earth et puis et puis le lui
donner facilement le prétexte à penser
que parce que c'est une femme qui a
rendu une décision dans ce centre de
cioni georges l'homme qu'ils divorçaient
et des oui ça quand même qu'il reste
dans ces professions comme dans dans la
magistrature
voilà beaucoup de travail à faire pour
la promotion des femmes mais aussi des
magistrates à la
nombreuse à quel niveau on commence à se
féminiser
stoecklé mais ça reste qu'on voyait les
tranches les plus élevées de la
magistrature et j'ouvre de politis
tentation
président
oui tout à fait allam rozès mais mais
c'est pour ça que pour moi le point du
milieu c'est un artifice d'ailleurs
c'est pas du tout la question il ya
tellement de choses à faire
dans une ase et vous vous parliez du
justiciable il ya ce réflexe là nous les
deux ans au barreau dans une réunion en
droit de la concurrence par exemple si
vous êtes là ça chante c'est le confrère
d'à côté qu'on va regarder comme tel
enfin moi c'est mon expérience est moins
présente chez les enseignants chercheurs
bon mais pour des raisons peut-être
culturel donc il ya encore beaucoup de
choses à faire mais c'est pas une
profession je crois que c'est
globalement la
justice reste de la société et qui
recueille par définition qui ne gère que
des situations conflictuelles sinon on
n'est pas donc on est toutes façons à
fleur de peau moi ce que ce qui est
certain c'est que je n'ai jamais
ressenti la moindre différence d'analysé
de laxisme de ses vérités que le
magistrat soit un homme qui zonent une
famille je serai serait bien mais
évidemment on avait même il ya même des
études statistiques sur les jurys à
l'époque est ce qu'un jury féminin
revient régie en fait on s'aperçoit que
non c'est ça dépend des affaires
peut-être aux dépens des affaires ça
dépend du milieu social ça dépend la
profession effectué samedi la culture de
la personne et à la sensibilité la
corruption à 6 par exemple regarder
quand même la composition du jury et oui
alors
je sais pas si c'est moi c'est pas qu'on
ne sait pas il faudrait pouvoir faire
deux ou trois procès identique avec des
ris a juridiquement masculin j'allais
plutôt fait bien plus tôt j'ai plutôt
âgées parce qu'il regrettait encore une
fois comment est ce que le jury de ce
deux jurés de 60 ans juste comme le juré
de 25 n'ont sans doute pas mais c'est
vrai qu'on va éviter moi je sais que mon
filtre parce que il n'a pas forcément de
vertu c'est la profession parce que
c'est plus on se dit peut-être que la
profession va influer sur la rue
sensibilité à l'infraction qui est
reprochée bon c'est mais je sais que
certainement pas aux hommes femmes comme
le disait un peu au doigt mouillé
syfy cité du jury d'assises
justement le le fait qu' un certain
nombre d'affaires vont être retirés au
jury populaire là encore pour accélérer
pour cela la procédure vous pensez que
c'est une bonne réforme mauvaise réforme
du bas ce qu'on peut regretter c'est que
la cour criminelle ça devait être est ce
une expérimentation puis il ya de ça va
devenir une règle à cause ou grâce au
confinement fin aux difficultés
sanitaires depuis la généralisation à
l'aîné d'abord des difficultés
sanitaires c'est à dire vas faire ça
entre magistrats on aura moins de jurés
parce que une session d'assises c'est 35
ou 40 personnes qui viennent sur dix a
littéralement
sur le reste ou en tout cas sur lac sur
la cour de versailles à part la présence
du jury populaire il n'y a aucune
différence de traitement de l'audience
je conçois en cour criminelle sans jurés
ou en cours d'assises avec jurés ça
c'est vraiment à versailles en tout cas
le jeu et jouer j'allais dire pas trop
l'expression le jeu mais elle est
vraiment l'esprit des réformes et là
c'est à dire qu'on juge comme avant mais
sans jurés est ce que c'est bon est-ce
que c'est pas bon je ne suis pas
convaincu que les jurés soient
naturellement laxiste pas non plus
naturellement c'est vers ce qui est
certain c'est que dans ce don dans
certains dossiers je trouve à mon
expérience mon retour c'est que ya
peut-être une plus grande homogénéité du
propos de l'avocat puisqu'il s'adresse à
des professionnels quand vous vous avez
adressé à déjeuner et vous appartient
quelquefois d'être pédagogique qui vous
ennuyer les magistrats il vous
appartient quelquefois d'être technique
et vous perdez les jurés et c'est vrai
que sur encore une fois mais chaque
dossier mérite sa réponse ce qui est
certain c'est que encore une fois quand
le quand le jeu et quand la règle est
respectée il ne s'agit que et qu'on n'a
pas perdu que c'est pas devenu une
grosse audience correctionnelle
je suis pas et je sais que certains
confrères sont vent debout génération
d'a3 criminelle ce qui est certain c'est
que en revanche moi je sais que le
chantier fondamental pour moi c'est que
la cour d'assises classique reste la
cour d'appel
oui parce que même dans l'esprit
c'est toujours c'est vingt six plats
simples mais c'est vrai qu'à une époque
d'ailleurs intellectuellement se dire
que le jury populaire qui est donc
souverain puisse être frappée d'appel
parce qu'on va rajouter 3
intellectuellement ça pose un problème
donc d'autres jurés seraient plus aurait
une analyse différente du peuple cc
c'est alors que là on à la cour d'appel
criminelle la cour d'assises criminels
qui retrouve je trouve son sens tout son
sens en disant les magistrats
professionnels et on parle et on va
donner la parole au peuple pour savoir
si on est toujours de cette fiction la
justice rendue au nom du peuple et le
peuple ne peut pas se tromper c'était
c'était sa demeure le fondement des
deizioù d'assises et libé pas d'appel à
bord a décollé j'étais écolier pas
d'appel parce que vous vendez pas mûr on
ne peut pas s'y tromper alors que ce
serait ce qui serait dramatique c'est
une suppression de la cour d'assises
parce que c'est la plus belle or je pars
en pénaliserait c'est la plus belle
juridiction dans le droit français c'est
la cour d'assises on a le temps on a le
luxe on a eu le temps d'essayer de
comprendre le temps d'entendre on
s'interroge surtout sur le pourquoi sur
le plancher le comment est ce luxe là il
faut absolument pas qu'on le garde parce
que c'est vraiment la garantie d'un
procès équitable
si
oui mais ça c'est tout les rêves vous
détestez métro florio pour que la peine
de mort a été supprimée qui a dit non
ils ont tué le métier
à part la peine capitale il reste des
sujets lire quand on veut parler de
trente ans par exemple ou de perpétuité
avait
alors passé dans la dernière partie je
sais moi qui aie il ya de la
contestation des juges et puis dans
cette contestation il ya le fait que
certains disent mais les juges sont en
train de prendre le pouvoir et
j'aimerais avoir votre réaction sur ce
sujet le bois des moutiers
[Musique]
alors on parle beaucoup il du
gouvernement des juges
[Musique]
ce qu'est ce qu'il faut penser de cette
forêt d'abord c'est varié parce que ça
dépend des il ya beaucoup de boban mais
déjà il faut prendre un peu de recul un
d'abord il ya eu plusieurs phénomènes
sans doute qui explique qu'ils
expliquent cette assertion sur le
pouvoir des juges c'est d'abord la
montée en puissance des juridictions
dans les années soixante dix avec le
conseil constitutionnel et puis avec la
place du conseil d'état avec les
autorités administratives indépendantes
avec les juges européens donc en effet
il ya eu plus d'offres de droit si j'ose
dire plus de possibilité de saisir le
juge mélangez m'aider avec cette
judiciarisation sert plus de saisine des
acteurs sociaux les sollicitations de
des juridictions tout ça peut déjà
expliqué cette place plus grande que
l'on que l'on donne aux juges les
affaires politiques et je pense au fond
à ce lien là c'est pour moi cette
accusation gouvernement des juges c'est
au fond une un décentrement de la notion
d'état en france traditionnellement le
droit et l'état sont liés ce qui n'est
pas le cas aux états unis où le droit là
est plutôt une protection du citoyen
contre l'état fédéral c'est pas du tout
notre cas en france et au fond il ya une
polycentrisme qui s'est installée avec
ses juridictions avec la mondialisation
et l'européanisation qui fait que cette
européanisation notamment il me semble à
donner plus de droits des droits et
libertés fondamentales aux citoyens qui
revendiquent leurs applications et donc
il sait si ces juridictions pour que les
copains restés beaucoup et au fond ils
n'ont plus même rapport à l'état il ya
une sorte d'autonomisation
initiale à l'égard voilà et à l'égard de
à l'égard du droit et puis un second
phénomène qui pour moi est en lien avec
les affaires politico-judiciaires c'est
qu'au fond aujourd'hui l'état aussi fait
appel au droit l'état qui était là iman
ont fait appel au droit parce qu'au fond
de politique a besoin dans la recherche
d'une éthique publique plus grande de 7
cet encadrement par le droit pour se
légitimer au fond et de la conception de
la démocratie c'est l'élection de nos
représentants et puis aujourd'hui est ce
que ce n'est pas aussi le citoyen qui
peut faire valoir ses droits et ses
libertés et qui au fond recherche de
l'assurance d'une forme d'éthique
publique donc tous ces phénomènes
expliquent pour moi cette idée de
gouvernement des juges aient leur place
au sieam quelque chose de beaucoup moins
effrayant comme monstre parce que je
crois fondamentalement à la force de nos
mécanismes démocratiques
je ne me sens pas du tout moi d'en
menacer dans ses frères de neige
sur ce sujet en panne devant le juge
qu'il faut le saisir c'est pas lui qui
ne prend pas le payer donc le juge quels
qu'ils soient qui soit terre civil pénal
administratif national ou international
il est saisi donc il répond à une
demande qui est fait quel que soit celui
qui fait la demande donc c'est bien
qu'on en a besoin donc moi je j'ai un
peu de mal à comprendre alors oui on
peut imaginer que par moments une
décision judiciaire prise par un ou
plusieurs juges est une influence
politique
on a un amant sur les chronologies de
certains procès ans s'est étonné de etc
mais le juge répond à une demande que ce
soit celle de la société que ce soit
celle d'un justiciable d'une victime que
ce soit celle d'une association peu
importe mais la réponse allait donner
parce qu'on lui demande dumont pense oui
c'est ça dont il n'y a pas de lien que
si on n'a pas si on estime qu'on est on
est garantie dans nos droits par le
saisit pas le juge donc ce n'est pas
vraiment pour moi une une prise de
pouvoir mais une réponse effectivement
qui peut avoir le la sérénité de la
règle de droit que la personne qui le
cio qui lui demande de répondre à pessac
le juge apporter c'est pas une prise de
pouvoir moi je n'ai pas le sentiment
après que la politisation des juges
quelquefois est une influence sur
certaines décisions peut-être s'en
douter que ce ça devrait c'est vrai
qu'on pourrait il est saturé mieux sont
ceux d'aujourd'hui
je me souviens même des contre-pouvoirs
c'est plutôt rassurant final moins qu'on
puisse savoir qu'on va faire de
bruay-en-artois par exemple
ça a toujours existé il ya des contres
mais n'y arrivons donc il ya pas de mise
en cause de la compta pas la séparation
des pouvoirs
phrase de bruno retailleau qui on a le
sentiment que l'état de droit et la
démocratie sont entrés en conflit
[Rires]
[Musique]
est ce que est ce que pour lui c'est ce
sentiment exprimé que trop de personnes
droit la démocratie ça va quand même un
peu de pair on
peut s'étonner si ceux ci le le fond de
sa pensée c'est que trop de personnalité
de sa famille politique sont tombés on
les fourches caudines de la justice on
peut comprendre une forme de frustration
de sa part mais malgré tout ce que je
vous disais c'est que moi je trouve ça
plutôt sain qu'un moment l'idée des
juges qu'ils puissent se prononcer sur
certaines à laquelle ils doivent tomber
justement de jeu dans le genre c'est la
justice et c'est justement elle le fait
que des hommes politiques cuisse à un
moment être mise en cause c'est là où on
voit que la séparation des pouvoirs joue
pleinement son oeuvre puisque le légiste
le le judiciaire n'hésite pas à aller
lorsque des infractions sont commises on
parle encore droit pénal sur le terrain
des hommes politiques et donc a fortiori
l'exécutif avec des décisions qui
d'ailleurs rendent hommage à la
démocratie on s'étonne quelquefois de la
sévérité de décisions rendues en droit
pénal des affaires ou en droit pénal
politico
judiciaire ce qui est certain c'est que
la justification de la sévérité de
certaines décisions elle est toujours
l'image de l'homme politique le rôle
qu'il avait à la société monsieur vous
êtes un ancien président monsieur vous
êtes un ancien ministre j'ai vous êtes
cse s'est systématiquement ce lac est
rappelé comme toile de fond la sévérité
apparente de la décision du monde c'est
repris par exemple on hurle on lui dit
pas le cieux on vous condamne sévèrement
parce que vous êtes d'abord politique
non on lui dit monsieur vous avez
l'image après on peut le discuter ces
dix minable et les avocats plaident
mélasse et c'est cette légitimité que
les politiques recherche publique
d'accord c'est que ça devient largement
son pagne deviens moi je serai j'aurais
n'y aura pas de problème avec moi il n'y
a pas d'affaires
photo nice
d'accord avec cette assertion on peut
pas faire par morceaux choisis comme ça
il faut avoir l'honnêteté de
intellectuelle de d'avoir un regard
global il ya eu combien de saisine des
juridictions donc du juge pour obtenir
plus de liberté individuelle on parle d'
atteinte à la démocratie par pas par le
juge il certains ont considéré par
exemple que sur cette atteinte à nos
libertés individuelles je parle
notamment des mesures sanitaires qui
était prise qui est qui sommes nous
allés voir pour que les mesures soient
analysés d'un point de vue juridique le
juge et le juge il n'a pas toujours été
du côté de l'état il a même été au
contraire du côté de la novation disant
non ça vous pouvez passer trop
ostentatoires donc encore une fois le
juge il répond à une question pour lui
pose il se saisit pas il se saisit pas
de fils voulait d'autres sujets on n'a
pas les aborder dont la mise en cause
par exemple d'aider des normes
européennes enfin qu'est ce qui fait que
ce qui est supérieur pas super les
traiter je vais parce qu'on en arrive à
la conclusion cette émission il ya les
états généraux de la justice qui se
tiennent actuellement 1
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous vous en
attendez je ne sais pas nous verrons
c'est très bien ça fait pas ça c'est
démocratique c'est à dire c'est les
nouvelles modalités de consultation
comme le fait la commission européenne
de 2,2 l'ensemble des parties prenantes
de la justice ce bien que le 200 c'est
très bien voilà on verra sous le
patronage d'un solo thé indépendant
présidée par jean-marc sauvé
vice-président
du conseil d'état c'est toujours bien de
réfléchir en commun à des thèmes mais ça
me paraît être une bonne démarche après
la question de ce que l'on fera de ces
conclusions ça je ne suis je ne sais pas
ce qu'il en sera mais en tout cas il
réfléchir c'est de toute façon une bonne
chose c'est ce que le seul problème
c'est pas celui du budget non non non
j'en vois pas ce qu'on en fait parce que
je crois qu'il n'y a pas ce qu'on aime
enfin dans la personne publique
présentée il ya une question bien sûr qu
on a souvent besoin de plus d'abandons
de nos budgets et qui a des tensions
budgétaires il ya quand même une
question d' allocation d'allotissement
bien placé des sommes et des budgets
dans ton dos exposé et il me semble que
dans la justice même si pour former
notamment des greffiers en chef on voit
à quel point certains sont dans des
difficultés budgétaires certains
tribunaux mais je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir à la répartition de ces
budgets à la façon dont on travaille et
c'est donc je crois pas que ce soit du
tout qu'une question de temps et
d'argent je ne crois pas je ne savais
pas qu'une question d'argent mais
un des pays qui dépensent le moins pour
7,6 à vous dans le champ il suffit
d'aller à des rentrées au rentrée
solennelle des juridictions pour
constater quand même qu'il ya un déficit
de personnel éclaircie un déficit de
personnel c'est aussi quelques fois un
déficit budgétaire on manque de moyens
pour certains aménagements on a on est
en train de travailler sur la
numérisation tout est compliqué et tout
est alors y'a pas que le budget mais
aussi la complexité d'un du parcours de
décisionnel sur certains sur certains
ministères entre la juridiction qui
appellent certains chose de ses voeux et
puis la réaction hystérique et d'une
complexité absolue les méandres qui sont
absolument incompréhensible pour un non
initié mais c'est les états généraux
tout est bon quand on consulte parce que
il y à aussi ça c'est à dire que vous
parliez d'affectation des budgets
quelquefois qui sont alloués sans vraie
coordination sans prise de consultation
de tous les acteurs c'est à dire de quoi
avez vous besoin que ce qu'on pourrait
améliorer là ça va dans le bon sens les
modalités de la consultation ont donné
lieu et ce serait trop complexe de le
détailler donné lieu à une
une gestation d'un certain
mécontentement de la profession parce
qu'on n'a pas compris comment
quelquefois la profession été consulté
alors que nous avons au moins deux
organismes de représentation nationale
qui sont cons ces nations et les
barreaux et la conférence des bâtonniers
bon voila c'était peut-être plus il
avait peut-être été urgent de consulter
cela avant d'en user d'autres modalités
mais tout ce qui va dans le sens de la
consultation au préalable maintenant on
fait ça invite il faut voir les délais
qu'on nous demande ça n'a pas vraiment
ça n'incite pas forcément à prendre le
temps de la réflexion donc ça va être
encore être fait un petit peu dans
l'urgence merci merci a fini j'avais une
autre question mais on n'aura pas le
temps de le traiter aujourd'hui ce qui
ferait pas faire une loi pour dire que
un avocat ne peut devenir
ministre de la justice que s'il n'a
jamais défendu personnes
éviterait les conflits d'intérêts merci
infiniment gré va bourse et donc vous
allez mettre la robe rouge notamment
pour la route nationale la robe noire
des avocats aussi merci beaucoup et qui
n'ont pas déjà geoffrey vienne et à très
vite pour un nouveau numéro de poche
[Musique]